opal did it again I don't know how they
keep creating such creative and
Innovative products but this is their
new tadpole webcam which absolutely blew
my mind and made me wonder why none of
the huge corporations were able to make
something like this but the small and
independent hardware company opal was
able to invent this and make it come to
life in this video I'll show you why
it's so special how it works the video
quality and how it is so different
compared to every other webcam
now I previously made a few videos on
the C1 from opal a small team that came
together from some of the biggest tech
companies because they had enough of the
terrible webcams on the market so they
had no other choice but to make their
own not only to fit their needs but
everybody else's no matter if you're a
regular employee an executive a parent a
student or a creative like MKBHD and
Casey neistat who actually backed the
project the C1 is truly amazing but some
people mention that it's too big and
heavy and because of its expensive
Hardware the price tag of $300 is a bit
too high for some people and because of
that they created the tadpole the second
chapter of opal which features some very
Innovative features and design tadpole
is about half the size and half the
price of the C1 and it is made for both
Mac and Windows laptops and we all know
how bad many of these Windows laptops
webcams are this is the first webcam
that is specifically made for your
laptop and while it's not made as a
replacement for a desktop webcam like
the C1 you get some great image quality
out of it without the huge size of a
regular webcam like the Logitech Brio
and while there are cheaper alternatives
they just don't compare to the size the
design and the Simplicity of tadpole
even the packaging is so unique and
simple and right when I opened it up I
was surprised by how tiny this thing is
while being really well built and both
the clip and the braided cable is built
right in which is actually the perfect
length and also includes this adjustment
bead and it is also designed to work
with their small carrying case which has
a really nice snap and it protects the
camera and the USBC connector and this
part is genius built right into the
connector they have a mute button now
most meeting software has that buil in
but that takes longer to enable and
sometimes you might have other windows
opened up on your computer and then if
somebody walks into your meeting you
can't quickly mute it but with this you
can just tap it to mute and unmute
yourself so even if the software
controls are locked you have Hardware
controls and muting this will not show
everybody that you are muted which can
be really helpful at times tadpull also
comes with this handy rubber privacy
cover which holds on snug to the camera
and it protects the lens now one of the
coolest Parts about the tadpool is their
new microphone Tech which basically
makes it only hear what the camera can
see which is what I'm using right now
check this out I got out this Bluetooth
speaker in order to play some background
noise like you would get in a noisy
coffee shop and Bam now tadpool is using
noise reduction and voice isolation to
get rid of that background noise and
focus on my voice and that is so helpful
in the real world and it's all packed
into a tiny webcam how cool is that and
of course it also improves your image
quality because this dels webcam looks
terrible even though it's a $3,000
laptop and here is the image quality
from the tadpole which lets you work
from anywhere now here is the best
webcam that you can get in a Macbook and
now we upgrad it to the tadpole which
has a much larger sensor and lens now I
know that people mention that you can
use your iPhone as well and if you have
the best iPhone the image quality is
great but it is big and I don't like
using it because you can't use your
phone or see your notifications you also
get the composer software with a bunch
of controls and extra features but you
don't have to use it tadpole works
perfectly by just clipping it on and by
plugging it in so go ahead and upgrade
your webcam experience with the super
portable tadpole by opal thank you guys
for watching and I will see you in the
next
[Music]
video